يختبئ بين أولئك الذين فروا من الموقف الأخير
لما يسمى بالخلافة الإسلامية
قادة هربوا من السجون مثل هؤلاء
الذين لجأوا إلى تركيا يتدفقون
بملايين الدولارات مدفوعين
بالانتقام يخططون لعمليات الهروب من السجن
الجماعية لإعادة بناء شبكة الإرهاب هذه
التحذيرات المتفجرة تأتي  من
رئيس المخابرات العسكرية المخضرم في
مقابلة حصرية مع CNN
وأكثر من ذلك بقليل من خلال تلك
العناصر الموجودة حاليًا في مناطق في تركيا
تلعب دورًا رئيسيًا والجهود الجديدة
لتجنيد مقاتلين كبار قادة الذين
فروا سراً في اتجاه
غازي عنتاب  ومناطق أخرى هم أعضاء رئيسيون في
تمويل التنظيم
ولديهم مبالغ طائلة من الأموال ،
بل ولديهم استثمارات في تركيا ،
قال الجنرال إنه سلم ملفًا من
تسعة من قادة داعش إلى مسؤولين عسكريين أتراك
في هذه الغرفة قبل شهر ،
لكننا لم نعرضه.  سمح لهم بتصوير
مذكرات توقيف عراقية بحق اثنين من هؤلاء الرجال
الذين قالوا إنهم خبراء في
صنع القنابل ومطلوبون على أرض الواقع  ص والقتل الجماعي
تقول مذكرات الاعتقال إنها تشكل
خطراً كبيراً في الشرق الأوسط
وإلى الغرب
قال المسؤولون الأتراك لشبكة CNN إنهم
يبحثون في المزاعم التي
تعقبها العراق وهاجم زعيم داعش السابق
أبو بكر البغدادي مما أجبره على الخروج من
العراق إلى سوريا.  حيث قُتل في نهاية المطاف
في أكتوبر / تشرين الأول ، لكن اللواء حذر من
أن تهديد داعش لا يزال قوياً.
حوالي 10000 مقاتل مزعوم محتجزون الآن
في سجون تحرسها القوات الديمقراطية السورية
غير واضح
منذ التوغل التركي الأخير في
المنطقة التي تعتبرها.  العناصر الكردية
في قوات سوريا الديمقراطية ، وهي جماعة إرهابية
تعرضت إدارة ترامب
لانتقادات واسعة لسحبها القوات الأمريكية التي
كانت تعمل مع قوات سوريا الديمقراطية من
المنطقة الحدودية ، ولم تفعل القوات الأوروبية
شيئًا للمساعدة في احتواء التهديد المحتمل
هنا ورفض معظمهم
إعادة مواطنيهم الذين  انضمت
القوات التركية إلى داعش ، حيث اعتقلت
العشرات من أعضاء داعش المزعومين مؤخرًا
واعتقلت 42 شخصًا جميعًا  متورط على سبيل المثال
في تحويلات مالية معقدة
للجماعة الإرهابية ولكن المخابرات العسكرية العراقية
تعتقد أن هذه السجون
وغيرها
مثلها يمكن مهاجمتها في أي وقت
بتمويل من قادة داعش الذين يعيشون في تركيا ،
ابن إلينوي هيباتيا الجدير بالاهتمام ،
وقد توصلنا إلى أن
النية الحقيقية لداعش هي  بدء مهمة
يسمونها تحطيم الدفاعات
لاقتحام السجون داخل العراق وسوريا
للتحرر بنعم وماذا تعتقد أنه يجب
القيام به حيال ذلك ،
يجب أن يكون هناك
جهد دولي كبير للتعامل مع هذا لأن هؤلاء
المجرمين يمكن أن يهربوا  المخيمات والعودة
إلى بلادهم بابا
ياجا توقفوا خطرًا كبيرًا على البلدان
في أوروبا وآسيا وشمال إفريقيا في
الدولة التي ظهرت فيها الخلافة الإرهابية
لأول مرة ، محذرةً من أنها لا تزال
تملك المال ونية أن
تولد من جديد
سام كيلي سي إن إن بغداد